the Joe Rogan experience his Nick taking
fights he announced on his Instagram
there's big news about a fight on a
story I guess some did you see his
interview with Ariel yep would you think
would you think I didn't I didn't think
he looked happy
no I thought you know was real troubled
and a lot of rambling I mean a lot of
thoughts trying to get out of his head
a lot of rants you know I mean I I think
I don't it's like but have you ever
watched an interview and be like damn
that was with him yeah like that was
super clear I mean I don't think that's
his jam you know no he's jam it's
[ __ ] people talk about that him and
Nate they're just like adds a little I
know it's it's tough because because
again we kicked this pot death off with
CT and stuff like that so it's like is
that a combination of him fighting is
that what's going on there those are the
years of the wars or is that just Ryan's
that just him we don't know but what I
don't know him well enough but I mean I
know guys but you know that are in that
same era they were having real problems
anytime we got I remember when he was
fighting in Strikeforce God remember his
fight with Paul Daley oh my god how
about a cyborg fight how good was he man
so good about his Frank Shamrock fight
holy [ __ ] man it's a shame what happened
with him and his brother in the UFC we
didn't get enough of it well the big sit
well Nate didn't get appreciate it
enough and after Vidia [ __ ] yeah and I
had always said that after the Conor
fight one of the reasons why those
fights were so big was Nate and for
whatever reason no one was putting that
together I'm like this guy's a superstar
people go crazy when they see him like
this is not there like a regular fight
his [ __ ] he smokes weed yeah he's a
stoner champion and and he says [ __ ] you
to the man everywhere for that
yeah I can even the vegans love him cuz
he sometimes he follows a vegan dude
checked all the boxes for a lot of
Manson's see he's like he's got so many
good things and he's tough as [ __ ] and
he'll fight anybody and he's been a
veteran he's been [ __ ] fighting for
every that so many war did you think of
his fight against Maz with all we
haven't talked in a long
I know MOSFET also good man he's so good
I got my little out of the three rounds
I thought it was best case for Nate to
that they did that that doctor stopped
the fight because I thought Maz Woodall
was setting up
to finish him and I and you know Nate
never been finished so he has been
finished Josh Tom that's right but I'm
saying you know it's it it was going
that way yeah it was best-case scenario
it could be like dude what the [ __ ]
where he doesn't lose any of that you
know right - yeah well the Josh Thompson
fight was more competitive up until the
moment Josh landed at how I can correct
that hike is it good fight Josh I think
josh is still winning that fight I have
to go back and watch it's more
competitive it was more competitive this
modeled off I didn't find it that can be
winded when they got the mic and went Oh
rematch went no there's no way and when
Dana is like no that's not have another
girl it was certainly competitive in
that Mazda doll was in a fight it wasn't
like you ran him over
no it's getting hard announcer but that
first round was devastating Maz Vidale
is [ __ ] good man he's [ __ ] smart
he sees things and he can act on things
that other guys just they just either
don't have the ability to the or they
don't throw themselves in the fire
correctly like he does and then he gets
out good his defense is on he's doing
everything he stands straight up - he's
got a totally different style like when
you see Maz Vidale stand like he's now
he's hard to grab the chain dude he
stand straight up he's got so much
confidence in his wrestling takedown
defense and his striking and his his
octagon IQ that when he puts it all
together he's able to fight with his
best stand up stance
you know he's fighting like and he makes
you aware very clear very quickly that
you're in danger with his hands he's
throwing bombs at your [ __ ] God think
about his experience men didn't think
about the guys he's beaten so now it's
here so you know when you talk to him
he's like the belt [ __ ] the belt I got
the BMF title yeah he's like Colby and
and kymaro or just that their third or
fourth options for me man there I'm
looking at Nick Diaz I'm looking at
Conor you know there's just he's like I
don't care about the belt man I see why
he would say that but I think it would
be a real shame if right now in his
prime of primes he didn't fight for the
title I just feel like he's so close and
that would be he's huge right now huge
he would rather see him fight Nick or
Conor no interesting no
well I want to see first no matter what
Kolbe a new smile you and you're getting
that yeah that's getting super excited
about that phenomenal fight once that's
done I want Maz Vidale to fight for the
title whoever's got the belt
I think if Maz Vidale and Nate Diaz or
Nick Diaz don't fight on the undercard
yourself deal I don't know if it's gonna
fight if they idea I have no idea I know
they want it and his management said the
UFC has reached out to Nick and they're
trying to figure that out if they do
make that fight happen I mean of course
I'm gonna be excited to see it of course
but my thoughts are that right now we're
experiencing Maz Vidal in this very
strange zone where you see fighters
enter into it whether it's through this
rededication or refocusing of his his
his intent and his discipline you know
he you know a story how he went and did
that reality show he came back and was
like he didn't have any food man he saw
this is [ __ ] South American reality
show he had to go to this village and
ask for food he also said he got like he
had time to like get out from in like
sit back yeah think about everything
going I was like all right this is what
I want to do and then came back was like
let's do it man then just he became this
superstar and I thought I just you know
when when when I meet those guys and you
off said no they're store and you get
around them but you just I have this
sense of just like I'm so happy for them
man like that that's why I talk about a
Nick Diaz fight for Jorge and I I talk
about a Conor McGregor fight because do
you not the title like tomorrow and
Colby they're not making real money man
you don't think that the Colby that
Kobe's gonna bring in a lot of people
know what record would say does it and I
love Kobe's fantastic fighter but as far
as ticket sales and pay-per-view snow
does from the UFC from the UFC this Kobe
was one big win right now like see he
hasn't fought in a while right he fights
Robbie Lawler before that it was a whole
year yes there hasn't been a lot of
activity him and Dana hate each other
but his crazy [ __ ] talking with his $3
suit and his [ __ ] maggot hat and his
bone the strippers if he gets through it
right yeah and the stripper tendon if he
gets through and he beats Camaro Oman
and any and it gets on the internet and
it becomes like a thing he could be the
next huge superstar
[Applause]